today we will be speaking with Dr John
Abramson who's been on the faculty of
Harvard Medical School for 25 years and
is author of the new book sickening how
big Pharma broke American Health Care
and how we can repair it a really great
to have you on today and I appreciate
your time
David it's a pleasure to be with you
thanks so you know when we talk about
the modern state of American Health Care
there's many cooks in the kitchen so to
speak and we can talk about insurance
companies we can talk about uh big
Pharma we can talk about our political
system and there's all of these
different factors in your book you talk
specifically about big Pharma talk to us
about why as a doctor that's where you
decided to focus in this book
right so I think the biggest American
medicine has enormous problems our costs
are way off the charts the health of
Americans is so inferior to the other
wealthy countries that about 480 000
Americans die in excess each year
there's trouble all over the place I
think the biggest cause of this trouble
that is unrecognized is the extent to
which the pharmaceutical and device
Industries control the knowledge that
doctors rely upon to formulate their
ideas about the best way to treat their
patients
so explain how that leads to
particular outcomes and disease
management which is often what it is
that that doctors are doing uh quite
quite frankly uh how what is that
relationship
so uh let's look at the Cancer moonshot
issue which is in the news now with uh
President Biden yep um the uh
anti-cancer drugs uh dominate clinical
research they're very expensive uh we
could cut uh cancer deaths in half in
the United States by attending to
preventive therapies preventive
interventions stop smoking obesity
environmental risks so what we're doing
because the Monies to be made in
developing new drugs and marketing them
what we do is create a body of of
so-called knowledge that's the results
of research that's commercially
sponsored that's about drugs drug
therapies for cancer and the uh
preventive side gets virtually no
attention because there's no money to be
made in it what we've got is a a market
failure where the money is invested in
high cost therapies whereas the benefit
could be reaped much more quickly less
expensive more effectively by attending
to preventive approaches so at the
primary care level often an idea is
floated that you could compensate
doctors not based on the number of
things that are done for lack of a
better term but instead for the sort of
successful management of a patient and
actually keeping them healthy rather
than sick and of course the devil would
be in the details in terms of exactly
how you do it and how you measure and
how you compensate but that's an idea
that's mentioned to put the focus back
on prevention rather than treatment does
that not if you could do that does that
not even really do enough because what
you're describing is so widespread and
established yeah it it doesn't do enough
yeah it's a good idea I think that uh
paying Primary Care docs to take care of
people instead of Performing units of
work would be a good idea and I think
Trying to minimize the number of
procedures that are done by changing the
payment for those procedures is a good
idea and that would be more effective
with Specialists than it would be with
primary care docs so you could capitate
Specialists for geographic area and uh
they would make so much money on salary
and if they did extra say cardiac
surgeries they wouldn't make money you
know if they did extra breast biopsies
they wouldn't make money so that that's
one way to approach it but the the
really the core lesion is that the
actual knowledge that doctors are
trained to trust
is invested in because it's going to
maximize Financial return to the drug
companies it's that knowledge that's the
problem and the idea that those though
that that the research projects get
turned into articles in medical journals
that are mostly written by the drug
companies that are peer reviewed but
virtually nobody in healthcare
understands that peer reviewers don't
have access to the data and the
guidelines that are written that set the
standards for uh good Community Practice
um uh and can be produced as evidence in
malpractice cases if you don't follow
them those guideline writers don't have
access to the clinical trial data and
having spent 10 years in litigation I
know that what's in that clinical trial
data the real data is often very
different from the data that ends up in
medical journals so what we've got is
doctors who are compelled to practice
so-called evidence based medicine which
is means the bottom two lines of the
abstract in the medical journal that's
what they said without understanding
that the whole research Enterprise is is
biased towards making money that the
results aren't peer reviewed that the
guidelines aren't peer reviewed and what
the doctors have been trained to trust
is the information that's going to best
help them take care of their patients is
not trustworthy there's this example
that I haven't read about admittedly for
a little bit so I hope I get the details
mostly right and I think maybe it's
related to exactly the mechanism you're
talking about which is when it came to
cholesterol there was a point in time
and again I don't know if it was a
couple years ago or more like a decade
or 12 years ago where the sort of uh
line at which point one might consider
recommending a Statin to a patient was
lowered so basically just the threshold
was changed nothing really changed about
one's likelihood of a cardiac event
nothing nothing really changed other
than instead of saying I don't know if
it was from 210 to 200 or 222 just a
change was made and it was now if the
patient is above this level consider a
Statin I don't know the origins of that
change I don't know if that change was
based in what we might call good good
science or as you talk about kind of
profit driven science or something else
but would that be the type of thing that
is influencing doctors to make certain
decisions that can be very profitable
that's exactly right and there are two
aspects to that one is there's never
been a study that compared Statin
therapy to Lifestyle intervention so the
drug companies don't want to do that
study because they can only lose because
they got they have all the Statin
business the other part is that I was
the lead author of an article in the
British medical journal in 2013 which
was exactly the time that you're talking
about when the standards were changed
and the numbers for cholesterol the the
study results are not transparent docs
don't have them guideline writers don't
have them but there's an organization in
Oxford called the cholesterol treatment
trialis collaboration that has the data
they made a Faustian bargain with the
drug companies that they would receive
their patient level data and do
meta-analyzes on that data and by
combining the statistical power of all
the different uh statin drugs uh effects
in clinical trials they would be able to
show that Staten has worked for more
people excuse me
so the CTT receives the primary data but
the part of their Faustian bargain was
they wouldn't release the primary data
so they control what doctors think they
know about these things so I wrote I was
the lead author of this article in bmj
and we recalculated the ctt's numbers
that they had published in Lancet that
justified lowering the threshold for
treating people with cholesterol
lowering medication and we showed that
for people at low risk who don't have
heart disease who have less than 20
percent 10-year risk that there was not
a mortality benefit that that their data
didn't show a mortality benefit and that
you had a treat between 100 and 140
people for five years with a Statin to
prevent one non-fatal heart attack or
stroke so we wrote that and
unfortunately we made a little mistake
in interpreting the frequency of side
effects in a complex study but it had
nothing to do with our conclusion and
the head of the CTT went absolutely
ballistic charged into the bmj editor's
office and demanded retraction of our
article which let yeah it was an
international kerfuffle it didn't get
much uh coverage here in the United
States but it sure got coverage in
Europe and it was pretty stressful the
editor appointed a six-person panel to
independently evaluate the demand for
retraction the panel voted unanimously
that there was nothing about our article
that required or deserved or merited uh
retraction and on we went but the CTT
being about a million times more
powerful than me and my three co-authors
had dominated the press the the
headlines so long about this attack on
statins that um we couldn't get our
message across to the public which is
hey if you are a low-risk person you may
want to take statins but you got to
understand it's not going to improve
your longevity and you have to treat 100
to 140 people for five years in order
for one to avoid one non-fatal
cardiovascular event and that's your
decision it's not you know I'm not
saying yes or no I'm saying doctors
should tell patients that that's what
the situation is and make let the
patients make a decision based on their
own values right
um to talk about something a little more
maybe superficial as it might be within
the the big Pharma space you know my
dad's a psychiatrist and he will often
talk to me about pharmaceutical reps
come to visit and they bring little
footballs and they bring pens and they
bring you know notepads and all this
sort of thing and they drop off
literature and sometimes there's
invitations to Lunge and sometimes
there's other things that kind of go
beyond that and of course there's this
very strange Dynamic where on the one
hand if it were straight up said the
idea of the Reps is to encourage the
prescription of medications many people
would say that that's obviously bad the
doctor should simply be deciding on the
merits whether there's a medication
that's appropriate for an individual or
that it isn't and then the
pharmaceutical companies will typically
say that's not why the reps are there
but at the same time if the presence of
these reps made no difference it doesn't
seem like a worthwhile expense for the
pharmaceutical companies so there's this
kind of weird dynamic where what are we
to interpret to be the point of these
representatives and what does what do we
know about the impact on the rates of
prescriptions of drugs when there are
verses are not pharmaceutical reps well
that's an easy question we know if a
doctor accepts a lunch that is valued at
twenty dollars single lunch that will
significantly change his or her
prescribing patterns so obviously the
drug companies aren't stupid and they
engage in this activity because it makes
the money that makes them more than it
costs them the the core issue here it
makes no sense on the surface but the
core issue is that doctors in general
like to uh reciprocate politeness and
kindness and warmth and they're not in
the habit of being discourteous to
people who come saying they're trying to
help them so the drug reps come and they
bring information some of it is reprints
from Journal articles some of it is
glossy charts that are very easy to
interpret but that information is
delivered because of its marketing value
not because of its informational value
because it's that's the information
that's selected that will most likely
convince the doctor to prescribe or
consider prescribing the drug so we've
got a situation where the drug reps are
playing one game they're taught how to
shake hands they're taught how to look
in the eye they're taught how to keep
notes about the kids birthdays and and
their wives anniversaries and they ask
all those questions and the doctors are
trying to get the best information they
can as quickly as they can to best serve
their patients and it's not a fair fight
because the drug reps know that their
job is to increase prescriptions they
get bonused on that they get evaluated
on it they have minders that go out and
watch them perform their sales Spiel and
they get graded on their sales Spiel so
it's a situation that exploits doctors
desire to have good information and
innate reaction to be polite where
politeness is offered to them the drug
reps know how to exploit the politeness
what's the lowest hanging fruit here if
we were to be able to make some changes
to the way this system works as you talk
about a lot of the information on which
doctors are making decisions is
information controlled by or created and
generated funded by the pharmaceutical
companies all these different things
that we've talked about we haven't even
touched on the direct advertising of
drugs to people via television which is
almost completely unique to the to the
United States what's the lowest hanging
fruit that would give us the most
dramatic improvements yeah so the lowest
hanging fruit is so low that it's a
stunning commentary on the power that's
controlling American Medicine
when a manuscript is submitted to a
medical journal usually the company has
played a role in preparing that
manuscript and the manuscript com
contains a very brief summary of the
data from that study the the peer
reviewers in the medical journal editors
don't get the data to see if the
manuscript is accurate and complete but
the manufacturers produce what's called
a clinical study report it's an official
document it's often two or three
thousand pages long of tabulated data
that purports and usually does present
the outcomes that the researchers said
they were going to study so they can't
pick and cherry pick their outcomes this
is a two or three thousand page document
that is prepared and it's searchable and
the the drug the the medical journals
they complain that they can't do
transparent peer review because they
don't have the resources to go through
the primary data and get statisticians
to line up the data with the way the
drug company coded and all that and
there's truth to that but this clinical
study report exists it would cause
nothing nothing for the journals to say
when you submit your article your
manuscript you must submit a clinical
study report if you want to redact a
little bit about how we make the gel
code or whatever you can do that if you
think it's a corporate secret but you
must admit that so why don't the
journals do this obvious thing and uh
and once you learn how to get around the
clinical study reports as I did in
litigation it's pretty quick to figure
out what's going on why don't they do it
they don't do it because they're in an
enormous conflict of interest position
they make a lot of their money from
selling reprints back to the drug
companies for the drug reps to hand out
to docs like your dad
so if the New England Journal is going
to make nine hundred thousand dollars
selling reprints of the vioxx article
that misled doctors and had convinced
them that it was safe to prescribe and
didn't increase the risk of
cardiovascular death the the New England
Journal wants to have that article
published in its pages and sell nine
hundred thousand uh reprints
if they had the clinical study report
they would have known that the article
was
um misleading would be too kind of word
but misleadingly omitted three heart
attacks and didn't present the data on
cardiovascular risk and the New England
Journal would have understood that this
was a bad drug it never should have been
on the market and it should have been
withdrawn immediately when the results
of that study came out but the New
England Journal won't do it because
they're going to miss the reprint sales
and the Lancet and Jama and it's that's
the way it works they missed the reprint
sales their advertising revenues will go
down their impact factor will go down
they won't be the world recognizes the
world's greatest Journal so what's
happening is the prestige much like The
Prestige of uh MGH Brigham in Boston
where the MGH Brigham they're they're
fabulous world-class hospitals they
spend a fortune on Advertising for their
branding and the journals are in the
same business of of maintaining their
branding for their journals and that
means that they're willing to sacrifice
the quality of the information that
doctors get when they read their
journals in order to maintain The
Branding factor of the journals
uh eye-opening stuff much of it not the
most uh exciting to read about but it is
important to know what's happening we've
been speaking with Dr John Abramson who
by the way we just lost your video but
we could hear you find the entire time
and it couldn't come as a better time at
a better time since this is the end of
the interview uh yeah there you are
you're back the book is sickening how
big Pharma broke American Healthcare and
how we can repair it we're linking to
the book and we really appreciate your
time today
well thanks very much for having me